طلب البابا فرانسيس خلال قداس عشية عيد الميلاد
في الفاتيكان من الناس أن يفعلوا
شيئًا جيدًا في وقت عيد الميلاد هذا ،
فقال إن الله ليس معجبًا بالمظاهر فقط
ولكنه يريد فعلًا ملموسًا
لا تدع وقت عيد الميلاد يمر ،
قال البابا دون أن يفعل شيئًا جيدًا
نعرف أن فرانسيس هو  يفعل شيئًا جيدًا
لشعب أوكرانيا في وقت عيد الميلاد هذا
، فهو ينظم
ملابس حرارية ليتم تسليمها هناك ،
وقد فتح الفاتيكان صفحة تبرعات
لأي شخص يرغب في المساهمة في هذا
الجهد ، إنه في
www.epella
e-p-p-e-l-a.com الذي يفتح حتى
يناير  6 بالنسبة للتبرعات ، ظل فرانسيس
جالسًا خلال القداس مساء يوم السبت ،
نعلم أنه يعاني من مشكلة مستمرة في الركبة
تسببت في إلغاء
رحلة إلى إفريقيا في الصيف الماضي ، تلك
الرحلة عادت الآن على الرغم من
مشكلة الركبة التي يعاني منها البابا.
جمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية وجنوب
السودان في نهاية يناير
ديليا غالاغر سي إن إن روما